[Musique]
ce famesine en fait est le fruit de de
rencontrre avec des des
autrices c'est une
publication qui est un petit peu comme
on dit bricolé c'est-à-dire un support
qui va rassembler des passionnés autour
d'un d'un sujet de
prédilection donc l'AMU m'a paru assez
évocateur et puis en plus laamue permet
également dans cette notion fanzime euh
bah de pouvoir tester des choses
[Musique]
elle dessine les volutes de fumée qui
s'échappe des bouches la poudre blanche
qu'on partage et qu'on sniffe les
boissons fortes les corps dénudés les
rires irréels et les sommeils
artificiels elle dessine aussi sur ses
bras et sur son ventre avec un petit
scalpel elle aime ça les incisions les
petites inflammations les cicatrices
scarifié dopé ivre de
liberté j'avais effectivement ce thème
en tête et aussi ce titre fille à la
peau de serpent j'aimais bien qu' cette
notion un petit peu guerrière comme
ça de la représentation féminine c'était
vraiment l'idée que chacune puisse se
sentir libre d'exprimer les chose de la
façon dont elle le souhaitait et de fait
de façon non non
censurée les vagues dansaient dans ces
lumières venues d'ailleurs nous nous
lovvions dans le sable encore tiède
blanches apparitions dansant sous la
lumière blafarde le ciel peuplé de
planètes scintillantes répondait à nos
désirs et lorsqu'une étoile filait nous
lancions nos vœux vers ces astres qui
nous contaient les histoire du passé
j'avais l'envie d'un d'un objet poche un
objet léger j'espérais qu'en fait ce
sera un objet que déjà pour tel qu'il
est on a envie de l'ouvrir de le
feuilleté comme un peu un gris gris un
porte bonheur enfin j'avais vraiment
l'objet d'un d'un objet
[Musique]
attachant